meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
der präsident der russischen föderation
wladimir wladimirowitsch putin
[Musik]
bitte nehmen sie platz
meine sehr verehrten mitglieder des
föderationsrates vertreter der
staatsduma meine sehr verehrten
bürgerinnen und bürger oslos die rede
vor dem trainingsende zum ersten mal so
früh im neuen jahr statt
denn es liegen wichtige soziale und
wirtschaftliche fragen für uns die doch
sehr dringlich sind die ziele sind
widergespiegelt in den nationalen
projekt in wir sprechen wir von einer
neuen ebene der regierung und im grunde
alle behördlichen institutionen und
natürlich geht es ja auch um den
direkten dialog mit unseren bürgern das
volk strebt nach entwicklung nach
veränderung sie möchten nach vorne
schauen
beruflich in anderen bereichen um ihren
lebensstandard zu erhöhen
und wir tragen die verantwortung für
konkrete maßnahmen
das volk weiß am besten was verändert
werden sollten in ihren gebieten städten
dörfern
wir müssen die maßnahmenpakete immer
weiter schnüren jahr für jahr um
ergebnisse für uns erfolg erzielen zu
können
denn es geht um eine gute lebensqualität
und das bedarf wie gesagt den beitrag
aller wenn wir unser land geschichtlich
betrachtet dann liegt unsere kraft in
unserem erfolg und damit komme ich zur
demografie wir sprechen darüber wie
viele kinder zur welt kommen in den
russischen familien einem jahr in fünf
in zehn jahren welchem menschen werden
daraus welchem beruf werden sie
ergreifen was werden sie tun für die
entwicklung ihres landes und welche
werte werden ihnen als säule in ihrem
leben dienen
wir haben heute eine bevölkerungsanzahl
von 147 millionen aber wir haben gerade
einen sehr demokratisch schwierigen teil
unserer geschichte bestritten dass diese
entwicklung hat angefangen in den frühen
2000er diese demografische veränderung
ist sehr schwierig für uns wir haben
immer mehr schüler zum beispiel doch im
moment ist die familiengründung ein
schwieriges thema und unsere bevölkerung
zahlen fallen und genau darin liegt
unsere demokratische herausforderung die
durchschnittliche geburtsrate ist ein
sehr wichtiger aspekt 2009 10 lag diese
zahl voraussichtlich 1,5 pro frau ist
das viel oder wenig 15 kinder pro mutter
für uns ist das zu wenig ich weiß nicht
wie das für andere europäische länder
zum beispiel es aber bei uns ist das
nicht genug
ähnliche zahl hatten wir im jahr 1943
während des großen vaterländischen
krieges noch schwieriger sei die lage
aus in den 90er jahren vor dem zerfall
der sowjetunion und da sprechen wir
lediglich von 1,01 prozent
und das ist natürlich viel zu wenig die
familienplanung wurde immer mehr verlegt
aufgrund der schwierigen lage und die
prognosen heutzutage beunruhigen uns
deswegen tragen wir die verantwortung
diese herausforderung anzugehen
deswegen müssen wir dazu beitragen dass
die bevölkerungszahlen wieder steigen
bis 2024 streben wir die zahl von 1,7 an
in diesem bereich es gibt natürlich
keinen universalschlüssel dazu es gibt
keine entscheidung die uns alle probleme
nehmen wird aber wir brauchen föderale
programme regierungsprogramm maßnahmen
denn das ist immerhin unsere wichtigste
nationale herausforderung der anstieg
der bevölkerungszahlen unseres landes
[Applaus]
wir sprechen hier von einer langfristig
ausgelegten strategie zur unterstützung
von familien dabei müssen wir uns auf
die realität stützen welche
herausforderungen haben heutzutage junge
familien mit vielen kindern eventuell
die wichtigste frage dabei ist zb die
herausforderung einen kita platz zu
finden für die kinder wir müssen dabei
regional tätig werden und bis ende 2021
müssen wir 255.000 neue kita plätze
schaffen
in den jahren 2018 und 2009 10 haben wir
statt 90.000 nur 78.000 kita plätze
schaffen können und letztendlich
sprechen dich hier von 37.000 realer
plätze
nach wie vor geht es hier um
ausbildungsfragen und die kitas sind
einfach nicht bereit mehr kinder
aufzunehmen
sehr geehrte vertreter der föderalen
subjekte meine damen und herren man darf
so nicht arbeiten
wir haben 77,7 tausend kita plätze
geschaffen und noch nicht mal umfassend
die hälfte kann nicht in betrieb
genommen werden die hälfte kann nicht in
anspruch genommen werden müssen weitere
177 1000 schaffen denn nur wenigen
jahren deswegen wende ich mich an sie
und bitte sie darum alles dafür zu tun
um das zu tun ich weiß dass es eine
herausforderung keine leichte aber das
muss doch getan werden
wir müssen die familien allumfassend
unterstützen
aber es gibt auch weitere probleme die
unsere demokratie noch direkter
bedrohung und das ist natürlich das sind
die niedrigen einkommens zahlen
unsere familien etwa 70 bis 80 prozent
der familien die unter dem
existenzminimum leben sind junge
familien mit kindern und das wissen sie
ganz genau wenn nicht nur ein elternteil
sollen dann beide arbeiten ist immer
noch das einkommen nicht ausreichend
deswegen wurden entscheidungen gefasst
januar 2020 werden folgende änderungen
in kraft treten
wir werden solche familien unterstützen
wenn du und fördermittel bereitstellen
für die erst- und zweitgeborenen wenn
das existenzminimum des kindes in der
jeweiligen region unterschritten wird
wir sprechen hier von etwa 11.000 rubel
pro monat pro kind und noch einmal
möchte ich betonen es ist hier
regionalabhängig sie haben ebenfalls
fördermittel für dreht kinder angewiesen
und deswegen haben wir zb moral in
sibirien und im fernen osten umfassende
pakete um unsere familien zu
unterstützen und ich denke sie verstehen
auch folgendes sobald das kind drei
jahre alt wird werden diese fördermittel
und zahlungen eingestellt und somit ist
es natürlich sehr wahrscheinlich dass
familien in die finanzielle bredouille
geraten und das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
natürlich verstehen wir alle dass
solange die kinder noch nicht zur schule
gehen die mütter auch in einer sehr
schwierigen finanziellen situation sind
oft werden kinder auch krank in dieser
phase die mutter kann nicht arbeiten
gehen wir haben da sehr viele probleme
die daran gekoppelt sind
deswegen schlage ich vor monatlich
kinder zu unterstützen und zwar kinder
von zwei bis sieben jahren
[Applaus]
und zwar ab dem ersten januar 20 20 des
laufenden jahres werden diese änderungen
greifen sind treffen dieser maßnahmen
und wie sollen diese maßnahmen
funktionieren folgendermaßen berechtigt
sind familien die unter dem
existenzminimum leben
die also wirklich in einer finanziell
prekären lage sich befinden dazu muss
ein antrag eingereicht werden die
einnahmen müssen angegeben werden und
ich möchte sie darauf hinweisen dass
dieses vorgehen möglichst simpel
gestaltet werden muss für unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger das sollte
vielleicht ein online-tool sein und zwar
in jedem föderation subjekt ich habe
bereits betont dass es fördere
abweichungen geben kann
abhängig vom figuration zu bieten das
mindeste an berechtigungs geldern liegt
bei 5.000 es ist sehr wichtig dass
unsere bevölkerung versteht wie dieses
neue system funktioniert
es gibt natürlich familien die nicht
unter dem existenzminimum leben die aber
dennoch unterstützung brauchen und auch
da haben wir weitere schritte vorgesehen
und zwar in jedem föderalen subjekt das
volle volumen beträgt 11 ein halb 1000
rubel pro kind im monat
[Applaus]
auch hier werden die zahlen variieren
aber im durchschnitt legen wir dabei
11.000 travel monatlich pro kind
natürlich werden wir ressourcen dafür
aufwenden müssen wir müssen das föderale
budget überdenken und deswegen wende ich
mich an sie diese aufgabe möglichst
schnell umzusetzen
diese arbeit muss natürlich auch
regional erfolgen was noch muss getan
werden und zwar genauso schnell
vergangenes jahr sprach ich bereit
darüber dass wir die sozialen verträge
ausbauen sollten wir sind dabei darauf
ausgerichtet und das allgemeine lebens
niveau anzuheben
wir müssen fördermittel und konkrete
hilfe zur verfügung stellen
zum thema aus und weiterbildung zur
unternehmensgründung und natürlich
tragen wir die verantwortung für unsere
bürgerinnen und bürger mit geringen
einnahmen aber auch die bürger müssen
natürlich da ihren beitrag leisten sie
müssen ihrer verantwortung gerecht
werden auch gegen deren kindern und
ihren familien
da brauchen wir weitere mechanismen die
effizienz der geltenden maßnahmen ist
leider noch nicht hoch genug der
einfluss ist zu gering
deswegen werde ich mich an sie und bitte
sie sich diesen sozialen thema
anzunehmen die regionen brauchen
unterstützung damit schon im jahr 2021
neue mechanismen gelten können so in
allen kreation subjekten
[Applaus]
sehr verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte vertreten der regionen
möchte ihre aufmerksamkeit darauf lenken
dass es dabei nicht um die anzahl der
sozialen verträge geht sondern um die
senkung der armut zahlen
vergangenes jahr stand ich hier und
meiner rede vor dem föderationsrat und
habe folgendes gesagt ich erinnere mich
sehr gut daran
ich habe gesagt jetzt kommen wir zum
wichtigsten zu der liebe
damals habe ich das programm des
mutterschafts kapitals vorgeschlagen der
kern liegt darin dass wir familien
unterstützen in der entscheidung ein
zweites kind zu bekommen
bis eine bis zum 31 dezember 2021 soll
dieses programm in kraft sein
die frage ist natürlich was tun in die
menschen nach dem 31 12 2021 das
programm des mutterschafts kapitals wird
verlängert
[Applaus]
und zwar mindestens bis zum 31 12 2000
heute brauchen diesen schritt er ist
unabdingbar
doch heute reicht dieser schritt alleine
nicht lösen die jungen menschen
unterstützen die sich für die
familiengründung entschieden haben und
deswegen möchte ich neue entscheidungen
vorstellen zum thema mutterschaft
kapital
diese seien ebenfalls ende diesen monats
in kraft treten
sogar bei der geburt des ersten kindes
ist eine familie ab jetzt berechtigt
mutterschafts kapital zu beziehen
nachdem das in kraft getreten ist
sprechen wir hier von insgesamt 466.000
rummel all diesen menschen haben bisher
dieses programm in kraft genommen
denn das ist eine unfassbare
unterstützung für familien und diese
unterstützung hilft den familien
natürlich auch dabei weitere den
beschluss für weitere kinder
so fasst nun doch das ist immer noch
nicht genug wir müssen mehr leisten
deswegen schlage ich vor dass
mutterschaft kapital anzuheben um
nochmal 150000
[Applaus]
mit denen das sind zusätzliche
fördermittel und eine familie erhält die
berechtigung dafür sofort bei der geburt
des zweiten kindes
deswegen sprechen wir hier von 616 1000
rubel an fördermitteln für solche
familien im weiteren verlauf fitter
betrag jährlich angepasst denke ich dass
wenn familien bereits ein kind haben
sollte bei der geburt des zweiten kindes
direkt die höhere stufe des
mutterschafts kapitals der familie zur
verfügung gestellt werden
[Applaus]
ich möchte dazu sagen dass bereits die
entscheidung getroffen worden ist das
bei der geburt eines dritten kindes
weitere 450.000 von der regierung
getragen werden vom staat um die
hypothek zu begleichen
das heißt eine familie mit drei kindern
wird in der lage sein ihre
lebenssituation zu verändern und über
eine million rubel zu investieren
eine hypothek oder in den erwerb einer
wohnung
natürlich behalten wir auch weiterhin in
den zinssatz von sechs prozent für
hypothekenkredite
diese sind fest angelegt für die gesamte
laufzeit der hypothekenkredite solcher
familien das ist ein enormer anstieg wir
haben auch ein soziales programm für die
junge familien vorbereitet und ich bitte
die banken aktien war an diesem programm
teilzunehmen
eine weitere frage ist enorm wichtig für
unser land
ich habe bereits über kinder und ihre
förderung von 3 bis 4
gesprochen doch das ist nicht alles was
wir tun können und sollten wie wenn ein
kind in die schule geht gibt es
natürlich eltern die möglichkeit wieder
arbeiten zu gehen vor allen dingen
betrifft das die mütter doch auch die
ausgaben steigen mit dem schul fähigen
alter des hundes
deswegen müssen wir familien auch in
dieser zeit unterstützen
deswegen finde ich sagen alle schüler
umsonst in der schule eine warme
mahlzeit erhalten können ab dem ersten
tag
wir haben sehr viel diskutiert in diesem
rahmen das möchte ich gar nicht
verheimlichen sagen es ist nicht sehr
was wir beschlossen haben
einige sagen dass menschen so wollen mit
einem höheren und einem niedrigen
einkommen das sie berechtigt sind die
gleichen fördermittel zu erhalten ist
vielleicht nicht ganz fair
das mag ja durchaus so sein aber es geht
aber unsere gesellschaft alle müssen
sich gleichberechtigt behandelt fühlen
es kann nicht sein dass kinder und
eltern die in einer schwierigen
finanziellen lage leben
es darf nicht sein dass sie das gefühl
haben dass sie ihr kind nicht
durchbringen können
das ist für unsere gesellschaft von
enormer bedeutung
sie wird oft gesagt sogar der
sowjetunion hatten sie solche maßnahmen
paket nicht das mag ja sein aber die
einkommensschere war damals nie so groß
wie heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
um unsere kinder gesund ernähren zu
können in den schulen müssen wir
fördermittel zur verfügung stellen und
zwar aus dem föderalen budget auch aus
den nationalen budgets
doch es geht hierbei nicht nur um geld
es geht auch darum dass wir in den
schulen die notwendigen infrastrukturen
einfügen gebrochen men saß in den
schulen
wir brauchen gute gesunde lebensmittel
und ich möchte auch sagen das sogar in
zeiten der sowjetunion das nicht
stattgefunden hat in diesem umfang wie
in den regionen und in den schulen die
bereit dazu sind den kindern warme
mahlzeiten bereitzustellen
die unterstützen wird wenn aber einige
schulen ihre bereitschaft noch nicht
kundgetan haben dann bitte ich meine
kolleginnen und kollegen diese
entwicklung zu forcieren
wir brauchen diese neuerung will braucht
eine gesunde warme mahlzeit für unsere
kinder
was möchte ich ihnen noch mit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen alle unsere
beschlossenen maßnahmen müssen darauf
ausgerichtet sein dass wir russland ein
effektives effizientes system schaffen
um unsere familien zu unterstützen damit
die menschen die unsere kinder groß
ziehen wären wäre das leben führen
können
ich habe bereits im breiten maßnahmen
gesprochen die wir ergriffen haben
diesen bereits ergebnisse sogar schon
länger sehen wir dieselbe größe in
russland haben wir deswegen eine neue
generation die herangezogen wird da sind
kinder die
gerade die schule gekommen sind die noch
einen kindergärten sind wir müssen aber
wir dürfen das wichtigste nicht
vergessen müssen daran denken dass das
glück einer familie in der liebe liegt
in der hingabe der eltern sich um die
kinder zu sorgen und das ist etwas was
uns ein
wir brauchen dieses gefühl von
sicherheit von einem rückzugsort das
sind unsere werte
das muss ganz natürlich seien für unser
volk das muss ein natürlicher
bestandteil des erwachsenen wir stehen
vor einer historischen aufgabe und das
ist der kern ihrer lösung
meine sehr verehrten kollegen wir müssen
unsere familien unterstützen
wir müssen das wertesystem stärken dabei
geht es immer um die zukunft dabei
stehen wir vor großen technologischen
veränderungen ist und befindet sich in
21 jahren
wir müssen unser potenzial vollkommen
erschöpfen und brauchen den richtigen
kontext damit unsere familien gedeihen
können damit alle kinder zugang zu
bildung haben
in der mitte des folgenden jahrzehnts
spiel werden wir etwa 19 millionen
schülerinnen und schüler in russland hat
und das und 6 millionen mehr als 2010
viele sagen ist es sehr schwierig in die
demografische entwicklung einzugreifen
deswegen sollte man keine großen
ressourcen aufwenden für die
demografische entwicklung aber die
praktik zeit und das genaue gegenteil
solche maßnahmen funktionieren wir haben
wunderbare ergebnisse
wir haben unsere ziele sogar übertroffen
wir haben sehr viele kinder in den
schulen so viele wie schon lange nicht
mehr
deswegen müssen sie konnten dass die
schulische bildung der kinder und eine
sehr hohe niveau umgesetzt
deswegen versprechen wir hier natürlich
nicht nur von demographischen faktoren
brauchen auch zusätzliche schulplätze
wir brauchen nationale bildungsprojekte
wir brauchen flexible lösungen wir
dürfen nicht einfach nur schulen bauen
wir müssen die gesamte bildungskette und
infrastruktur nutzen um diese ziele zu
erreichen und auch der einsatz von neuen
technologien ist dabei unabdingbar
fast alle schulen in russland haben
heute internetzugang wir schreiben das
jahr 2021 deswegen brauchen wir nicht
mehr nur internet wir brauchen schnelles
internet
die schülerinnen und schüler gebrauchen
die digitale transformation
wir müssen sicherstellen dass sowohl
schüler wie auch lehrer den umgang damit
gelernt haben wir brauchen einen zugang
zu ausbildung und das betrifft jedes
einzelne kind
wir haben sehr viele anti ist die
gefördert werden
mit einem technischen hintergrund
natürlich geht es auch dabei um den
kunst und recht musikunterricht
kulturelle programme dafür haben wir
acht milliarden rubel zur verfügung
gestellt für die anschaffung von
musikinstrumenten unter anderem aber das
problem ist viel weiter wie viele
solcher strukturen sind veraltet
deswegen wende ich mich an die
anwesenden regierungsvertreter der
ordnung zu schaffen in ihren regionen
[Applaus]